amine elias bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
deux mois après l'explosion qui a ravagé
la capitale perd août quelle est
aujourd'hui la situation sur place
et malheureusement le liban il est si on
peut le dire en chute libre maintenant
que ce soit sur le plan économique sur
le plan financier et ce qui est le plus
dangereux il est en chute libre sur le
plan politique alors l'économie
libanaise et maintenant elle et elle et
elle est totalement paralysée en raison
de la politique menée par les banques au
liban qui interdire aux libanais leurs
actions imaginez est ce assez et
concernant la l'économie et sur le plan
financier la livre libanaise
elle a perdu entre 500 et 600 conscient
de sa valeur +2 57% de la bible sous le
seuil de la pauvreté et le pouvaient les
libanais qui sont en train de perdre de
plus en plus le pouvoir d'achat
et c'est une catastrophe ça va ça va
aboutir à une catastrophe sociale pour
les libanais et ce qui est le plus
dangereux c'est le le plan politique
depuis depuis depuis des années on a pas
on parle pas de de notre de notre réel
problème disons au liban m libre années
qu'ils sont en train de repenser leur
union maintenant les libanais sont en
train de repenser leur volonté de vivre
ensemble et à mon avis ça c'est le point
qui est le plus dangereux de notre crise
actuelle il ya beaucoup de penser aux
libanais il ya beaucoup de délicatesse
qui sont en train de dire voilà
l'expérience de vivre ensemble entre
chrétiens et musulmans au liban elle a
échoué
il faut penser à quelque chose de
nouveau
justement quelles solutions à court et
long terme pour faire évoluer le
quotidien d'un délibéré que vous venez
d'écrire ça ça c'est notre passé notre
le trad tragédie au liban il n'y a pas
d'aidés des issues
disons réalisable et maintenant la seule
peut être la seule la seule initiative
qui était un peu rire un peu imaginable
et réalisables au liban c'est à
l'initiative lancée par le président
français emmanuel macron qu'on a appelé
le gouvernement de mission et jusqu'à
maintenant elle a raté les libanais
qu'ils ont raté cette cette initiative
sur le long terme nous sommes vraiment
les libanais qui sont vraiment les
victimes d'un régime mafieux qui a été
établi depuis les années 90 et ce régime
mafieux il ne va pas laisser laisser sa
place à la nouvelle génération disons
libanaise il y à un mouvement populaire
de tendance laïque et kiki qui est en
mouvement depuis les années depuis
depuis l'année 2000 et 2000 2010 et 2011
2015 et 2019 mais malheureusement ce
mouvement populaire banque faillie qu'il
est minoritaire
il est impuissant il n'est pas capable à
produire un changement politique au
liban malheureusement on a parlé de
l'enquète on sait que pour l'instant
plusieurs hauts responsables des
autorités portuaires et douanières ont
été arrêtés il n'y a toujours pas eu de
communication officielle sur les causes
du drame est ce que selon vous ce sont
les conséquences d'un système politique
gong rennais justement par la corruption
bien sûr bien sûr depuis depuis les
années 90 est vraiment on a établi et on
a tricoté je le dis tricoter un régime
de corruption qu'on n'a jamais vécu au
liban qu on n'a jamais conduit au liban
bien sûr il y avait des camps comme
comme c'est finalement c'est la réalité
il ya de la corruption
peut-être partout mais c'était pas
c'était pas un régime vraiment de
corruption qui est bien tricoté ce qui
s'est passé le 4 août
au port de beyrouth bien sûr c'est la
conséquence de la négligence c'est là
qu'on perd conséquence de l'incompétence
de la médiocrité des autorités pour qui
aime bien sûr c'est la conséquence d'un
régime politique mafieux et corrompu et
nous les libanais on attend chaque jour
une nouvelle catastrophe parce qu'on
s'est non seulement le port avec m même
les goûts pauvres même tout militaire au
liban même toute administration au liban
elle est assez assez assez corrompus on
sait pas vraiment on ne sait pas comment
faire pour se libérer de ce système de
corruption qui qui qui vraiment qui
risque que notre pays ce pays qui a été
qualifié de suisse d'orient avant les
années 60 et 75 on rit on risque tous
les libanais maintenant de perdre notre
pays malheureusement dans la question
mais très rapidement
quel est l'état d'esprit des libanais
même après cette catastrophe est ce
qu'aujourd'hui craignent que la vérité
ne soit jamais connu je sais que
beaucoup attendent que justice soit
faite
oui ben personne à un espoir au liban
que les jeux que la justice soit faite
on a espoir malheureusement parce que
nous sommes traumatisés au liban les
libanais sont vraiment traumatisé après
le 4 août et ce qui fait que c'est
traumatise à sion soit plus lourd c'est
que ils sont toujours très puissant les
tenants de ce régime mafieux ils sont
très puissants sont qu'ils ont même été
capables à faire rater l'initiative
française au liban
elles nous sont victimes vraiment les
libanais sont victimes sur ces mafieux
et je pense que libanais et dont le son
à tous les peuples démocratiques au
monde
ne laissez pas vos pays entre les mains
des gens médiocres qu'incompétent et les
laisons de mafia merci merci beaucoup
entre cas monsieur aminé gas d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur d'histoire et de
sciences politiques à l'université
libanaise